hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to reimagine the game the
second game in the game trilogy that
I've played the game of before this one
that everyone seemed to enjoy and
thought was hilarious except that it was
slightly offensive or maybe that added
to it for you either way this is the
second one in this series and I'm very
eager to give it a go ok that's how
we're gonna start this all hate portal
BOTS wherever the hell you are hello
boob girl I don't know who that Justin
Bieber that old Justin Bieber set the
avatar lady that's top hat guy that's
another avatar leader either way let's
go reimagine the game revolutions ruins
oh and rainbows I don't see any rainbows
but this is oh so familiar to us Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
achievements small step giant leap what
the hell is going on now
no not really why is there a troll face
oh there's the rainbow you want to
starts even just for starting yes is
that Justin Bieber geez fine okay
achievement non sense of entitlement
thank you that's exactly what I needed
right now
oh my god there's so much going on in
the background I'm definitely gonna need
to put a seizure warning in this that's
Lady Gaga's outfit I don't know who the
hell that is
American hat and OH think inside out
what did I do bad did I do good I don't
think you understand the gravity of the
situation
well puns were not required no one told
me to bring all my puns I would have
brought weight along when I was playing
this I think I won maybe
inception the game in a game you go
level up in okay never mind then
I'm assuming he was some joke about
going down another pun my oh that's cool
yo dawg i heard you like dreams okay
then
excuse me pardon I need mine oh oh this
is messing with my brain I haven't seen
the inception movie in a while we have
to go deeper Oh am I am I supposed to go
through it oh okay
looks like I'm not gonna make the
achievement I'm not that I really care
about am I supposed to go faceplant into
the explosives or is that something I'm
not supposed to do oh well alright then
me inception okay inception an
exceptional film with great reception
about dream conception and deception
contraception I don't think those
options mean exactly what they think it
means rainbows Oh
double rainbow all the way job if you
paid attention on the internal screen
you know what to do
maybe I keep getting impaled on these
unicorn horns that's all that's the only
thing I can assume that these are maybe
I go this way
no that's certain death too sure is a
lot of blood being bleed it out of my
body yeah there we go okay I did it
it's going to be another one oh very
very close double rainbow all the way
Java okay hey
oh wow this is actually really really
cool like no joke this is really funky
funkalicious and fresh oh god that is oh
I know what I need to do okay so I need
to save this for okay nevermind that was
not
what I needed to do it all there we go I
just need to cut corner or many harm
many oh love
I'm swimming there to play on harmony
I'm assuming this is going to be wages
type of game cuz it's just gonna be so
many puns from beginning to end
Lady Gaga the game that me dress looks
rah rah rah ha ha hello on Lady Gaga not
British at all dunno war I have a
British actor it's not every day that a
vote Super Meat Boy oh it's a super mean
explosions Lady Gaga boy I'm not very
God these controls are Oh hold jump oh
ok so I I don't I don't need to tap it I
just need to hold it oh my god I got it
oh my god I got it hey hey hey me Lady
Gaga me go jump in my meat dress me
sticky - Wow
this is so relevant to 2011
my god I feel like I'm right in that
time period again am I supposed to be on
this way I don't know what's to be doing
now oh so cool I love it so much
literally is game the game this time
Alejandro who the hell was all ahan drew
anyway okay that didn't work here we go
there we go no no I'm assuming that was
the royalty-free Lady Gaga music that
the developer found sexual and shocking
sex sells vex sells the pokerface
Holly ale ale Jandro number my
telephones dis dis stops dis dis door in
facebook the game the tough though these
characters don't have faces okay alright
thank you thank you hello
why are you trying to poke me big glyph
lady I don't want any of your sass don't
give me no lip that don't poke me back
oh he poked me into an explosion
he poked sploded me oh my god get away
from me no they keep blowing up my blams
it's gonna get away from the people yeah
wow you are persistent I don't want to
be your friend I have a very private
Facebook life stop Peter poking me like
if Facebook uses like and then like
YouTube users like then like why
shouldn't everyone like like like a g6 a
plastic bag P Diddy the only girl in the
world
oh man music references I've had the
game disorientation loss ah Steve Jobs
back when he was still alive
that's sad all right oh it's like portal
okay he's dead Gabriel wasn't happy this
time that's a terrible joke for me Mike
no Steve Jobs
don't die over and over again oh oh no
all the Mac fans are gonna be so mad at
me I keep making them die over and over
okay there we go
oh that's very lovely yeah okay
I forget what which one did I go in uh
okay ha Wow I can admit this really
creative and clever like no joke
obviously put a lot of obviously uh
obviously a lot of programming work went
into it is what I'm trying to say okay
oh okay okay so I just need to gently
wait I will fall into my position I
don't need to actually do anything there
we go now what am I gonna do to avoid
certain death here I don't know pry some
stupid like this oh god don't hit that
one no oh okay okay so I just need to
wait if I wait and will fall into place
I don't need to do nothing okay good for
me
okay so nutritious oh well that's not
cake at all mocking the iPad in a flash
game I am so brave
well now most flash game developers are
making lots of money making apps on the
iPad so now really about 23 oh no that
was God that was Oh eleven eleven was a
while ago now it's so weird switch
character one two three okay so what is
this okay so this is woody hi I'm woody
howdy howdy howdy
what's almost said woody woody woody I'm
woody buzz I'm buzz buzz buzz buzz don't
mind me I'm a play on Buzz Aldrin okay
so springy we can springy do am I
supposed to build a fort this is totally
LittleBigPlanet right now like not even
close to not be in that yeah okay going
going okay yeah you were almost up there
just okay hey okay all right if you
could not be that okay okay this is well
ah there we go chew gum hello all right
then so what am i why do I have a
collection of toys what good is this to
me anymore I'm gonna don't I'm 25 years
old I'll never love these guys again
[Music]
wait what was with the heartbreak am i
supposed to press these buttons or am I
not supposed to press these buttons
[Music]
anybody left
oh just piggy pig-pig into the oven
oh oh stop crying it's just a story
about having a loved one leave you after
so many years and you lose your previous
meaning to your life in the face of this
existential crisis you regrets into an
infant a stage of denial no owners means
no heartbreak you alienate your friends
and lie to yourself insisting that
everything can still go back to the way
it always was but through enduring your
personal purgatory you learn to come to
terms with the really a reality you
properly mourn your loss sang one last
goodbye to your loved one for you
finally realized it so for the best for
both of you and with your companions by
your side you can finally move on that's
like a happier ending right oh that was
actually a profound statement and
actually was kind of the message of Toy
Story 3 anyway Oh lost the game I don't
know lost I never watched it I'm gonna
be totally lost in these references
oh wow oh I'm the smoke monster whatever
that may be okay that that didn't work
oh okay I don't know this is like
spoilers for lost or anything but I
don't know this is so cool and creative
this soukra it's good to be creative
when you're thinking creatively oh I
need to remember that that looks like
something tonight I don't have driver
I don't 4 8 15 16 23 42 4 8 15 16 23 to
42 4 8 15 16 23 42
okay help me remember that guys I'm not
gonna remember that at all no no no
right here okay Wow
what am I supposed to do here why am I
so lost why am I so lost in lost ok
there's aa B seat am I supposed to just
throw myself up BAM
nope almost yeah okay almost got ya okay
okay this worked far better before there
we go god I gotta got it there damn that
took a while alright yeah yeah alright
for me I'm a good person
oh okay it's alright
what that didn't do that brother what's
up here anything no no secrets all right
I did it I did it I was skilled lost
doesn't have that many characters this
is slightly more than the number of
characters at Twitter messages that's a
lot of characters character putts
oh no war give me a verb rebel give me a
noun rebel what's this for
Oh intermission an hour from the boss
welcome to the intermission this is a
good time to collect our thoughts about
what the hell just happened to us and
reflect upon we what we have borne
witness to thus far juxtaposing the
mainstream Gaga with the NDB boy deeply
moved me I know me too
plus a bold expression if not singular
rainbows nor double rainbows a triple
rainbows move me deeply I know
however the Freudian symbolism Toy Story
seems too heavy hadn't it okay since
when des was talking about its own
mother I mean we get it Annie as a
single mom we don't need to know that
hurt or that's a funny joke there but I
digress I think you do
overall promising start to a
scintillating magnum opus one to which
we may observe through a high-class
particle you seem to be screaming a lot
for a high class particle guy hi Claire
getting wasted on my classroom waste
you're high class or any place do I need
to keep reading this forever or should I
actually move on here if you have any
truth be told
something profound to see I'm actually
pretty wasted right now I would believe
it you look pretty wasted oh my appears
I avoid myself congratulations good for
you you get an achievement for that
sentence is some strawberries why are
you pissing strawberries hmm yeah it's
quiet are you done are you quite done
now word from the okay thank you comic
book movies the game reading 24 panels
per second okay alright
hey hey I did it
and then I stumble upon the worst hack
excuse for a punchline the meta
self-deprecatory joke well that was it
no Scott Pilgrim hey you try making a
game that parodies a movie based on a
comic book that parodies games okay I
guess since I exclaimed that's it that
was a good explanation of why that was
in blockbuster the game is about to come
here about movies Oh God Oh what I
thought I was gonna death again three
need the auto-tune in movies when catch
it makes a 3d music video run just
[ __ ] run what you're gonna make fun
of everybody in this way but you can't
say [ __ ] and airports ago oh boy
fighting for freedom oh here comes a
political statement
Oh undress up the game drag and drop oh
wow let's see if you have any security
threats under here hmm what about this
yeah this was grab the threatening yeah
what's under here oh sorry I was
invading your privacy for well oh yes of
course
[Laughter]
goddamn Oh
oh is that where that gif I think I've
seen that gif of just like the noodley
arm
troll face guy before but oh man tsa
loves tits and ass you didn't need that
privacy you could log out of Facebook
anyways mmm WikiLeaks the game loves
transparency get it okay WikiLeaks
I'm not Edward Snowden was his name I
can't remember his name the guy ben de
Blancs blumburtt blump represented in
that movie about WikiLeaks you like that
you like that you like that you like
that leaked huh whoa goodness gracious
my goodness okay Wow whoa hey uh hi
how's it going it's gonna do this real
quick oh no holy Ted so just kill people
oh no boying
no I didn't want to do that sorry pardon
me kitty okay
merica Mir America
I've trust me I'm American I'm too
American sweet [ __ ] party supply
[Laughter]
it's just this tasteful tasteful
commentary on society as a whole long
table gate oh you have nothing to fear
apparently I'm Obama
oh I'm shocked that people are shocked
maybe we're just shocked at all this
hasn't already leaked out on some
politicians Facebook middle-class female
demographic aged 12 to 18 the game give
or take a couple Cougars okay wonder
what this is gonna say hold down space
for your beaver call I'm all right okay
how am I supposed to oh that's right
okay that's it that's much less oh this
is back when Miley Cyrus didn't go
completely bonkers not that she did if
anyone's a big fan of Miley Cyrus out
there she just worked a lot not bonkers
not at all not crazy
no I'm not saying she's crazy what are
you saying I'm just saying she twerks a
lot knows how to play on our knees and
she wrote a wrecking ball anyway what am
i doing I forget what I'm doing here oh
yeah so please don't take this level as
sexist oh wait whoa look I think it's
good women and teens have more to say in
media so please don't take this level 6
is Ray just some best friends or
underage girls Wow
all right then hello Cyrus
the guys the guys I can't tell you what
if it is looking real grown bottle under
each to lust from me I'm all the rage
when I'm on stage rocket drill is how
I've seen well I get blinks as long as
those are my tracks to be black baby the
baby one less lonely girl with my
sisters my world 2.0 found off YouTube's
coffee - Peters want me home cuz I'm
John and me making my friends means
breaking Hongbin and I love it wait wait
wait you know that was what I thought
would happen if Bieber's agent tried to
make him more macho well I was animating
this Bieber killed a cop on CSI oh yeah
that was the thing that happened yes
what more raging debate happen in the
comments as per you don't fall okay wait
which side am I supposed to be on oh no
I can do that again Haiti Brazil Chile
China New Zealand Japan some world's
just wonderful oh that's so sad Oh is
earthquakes a game I totally forgot that
exactly a thing damn it this is so bad
oh they're randomly generated that's
that's wait what if it's randomly you
didn't give me a whole lot to go on here
this is zebra Oh God why why why God
defeat this is so offensive which side
you're gonna be on huh what's that oh
that side huh oh goodness gracious why
are you not giving me much oh you ruined
it for me
Oh
cheap oh no oh this is oils bill hey hey
ho wash press space to wipe the pillow
[Laughter]
[Music]
clean it up your Pelican it makes me
more money well how's the thing yep oh
well I promptly died so that that
Pelican sacrifice went in total vain
here mostly because I'm a freaking idiot
oh okay there we go
hey mr. Pelican I need you for things
skinny tie well that'll soak up a
pelican real quick BAM ski okay no
pelicans here
they're gonna find me a pelican where
did you come here you I'm gonna get you
I need this yep I need to skip back
there oh no no no no he's already oiled
up enough I guess that's good bamboo ski
anybody you're gonna come in bastard
here don't deserve to be happy and free
and natural oh geez boil to get up oh
okay I get I get I get I did I did a I
did a doof I do stab it I need ya and
then I need to get more okay I need to
get more oil because oh god dammit
you're a son of a [ __ ] compared to
games everybody on the in and it's gonna
see like okay now there's oil yeah okay
so now I can get up there okay okay now
I can flush that guy you get in there
yeah all right so now this okay whoa
well that was rather spur DOL I wasn't
ready for why don't you just lather me
up game I'm ready I don't mind getting
oiled up at least oiling up these
pelicans
I'm a professional pelican oiler if you
didn't know what I'm saying okay I'm
just biding time for my idiocy to set
aside so that I can actually do
something okay this is also good not
good with mechanics I think my
livestream with Superboy will show that
very clearly yeah okay this is good like
this give me more give me more of that
sweet oily substance all over this well
alright that Pelican exploded
all right away come here you you have a
job to fulfill for the great American or
those British Petroleum I guess until I
panicked I'm surprised these enormous
Jets of flame aren't causing these
pelicans to just explode spontaneously
while they're in my hands well or I
could suck more how about I do that
how about I become the champion of
oiling and sucking oh yeah I feel the
currents within my balls Oh what were
you saying
I have no idea yeah that didn't work
well [ __ ] let me up a little bit
become the master of rubbing my Pelican
and then press your button doesn't every
British man oil up their pelicans for
the good of Britain land
I saw the Kingsmen I'm an expert on
Britain amendment I'm glad I know all's
well that bends well ends BP oil well in
hindsight it looks like he's humping the
pelvic in either way baby [ __ ] the mover
oh good I love it the terrible timeline
of infinite power trollface well April
2010 BP oil spill
March 2011 nuclear Fuchs Oh
how's a sad time 2011 wind turbine
decapitation oh my god that happened
really solar power plant
we're sunburn accident in history
really
[Music]
I'm looking at you man I see that as are
you I'm fine actually I just got over
being sick I don't know what colors are
that's a penis hey how dare you talk
about the fatal friend I like that I'll
have you know that's a sacred mother
don't you okay all right bye
apps again give touch screens to finger
Oh back to Steve Jobs are we okay throw
the phone Angry Birds at me
I don't know no that didn't even need to
do damn thing well alright maybe I did
because that didn't seem to work okay
Nikes I done I win
apparently somehow hello doodle jump
just a copy of this guy oh hey I'm doing
amazingly well
whoa yes everything I've ever wanted
unlimited power is a forbidden yeah yes
I'll take that yes no far naps
[Music]
apprehension over Apple applications
because it appears paving Apple's App
Store rules is appalling
very clever day party the game bringing
you to a boil what kind of tea party
we're talking about oh yeah American
rather silly Tea Party oh no wait oh oh
I get it
I need technically we're tea bagging you
Obama aren't we me just saying that and
putting on Internet's putting me on some
NSA watch lists okay yeah well this
worked before
I'm not bad at games not I'm not the
game's up
Oh son of a bad scar
I'm not not calling Obama son of a [ __ ]
I have no political reference one way or
another there we go god damn you suck
don't know what this level is supposed
to mean feel free to make your own
political metaphor I think I was doing
just fine on my own
police are knocking on my door as we
speak all right
Obama's birth certificate Osama's death
certificate what the hell else do you
want okay fine
social networks a game Mubarak cuts off
the internet oh don't you poke me again
you pokey piglet bastards and lady no
hey my spell myspace is actually back I
think anyway life is this a game and now
with social gaming first one to rewind
prostituta forward what they don't work
Oh Oh YouTube the game look at YouTube
the game I'm not on here I wasn't on
here yet see end it all I like the part
we're coming okay how do I get up there
get up there oh I get it that's clever
oh that's clever oh that is clever loser
yeah there was okay I like it when
things are clever okay
oh no damn it it's gonna take a while
now I go back now I go forward to the
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
full circle and that's actually what's
happening right now this game has
actually made its way back onto YouTube
probably several times now the trans
justify the memes who gets sick of viral
videos not me not me at all
I love them always bisexual musicians
the game all right here we go changing
changing gears really quickly kind of
grinded it on the way oh wait what am i
doing
oh I see okay so then super meat gaga
welp that didn't work yep okay
and then boob lady Oh Katy Perry I
didn't get that at all okay so yeah no
no you're supposed to go over no no Lady
Gaga I can go up there you go there what
does Katy Perry's superpower again come
back I do Lady Gaga koala day please
thank you so Katie's Perry's power is
double jump because the same
Oh No okay so Katy Perry can get over
here wherever this is this is Ke$ha yeah
might be Kusha yeah it's Ke$ha Ke$ha can
go up here Lady Gaga can go down to the
bottom Katy Perry can go here with her
oh those are whipped cream boobs oh
those aren't real boobs that's not
obscene at all those are those are those
are whipped boobs okay all right ha now
I'm glad I won't have to censor this
video it's been so crude so far I can't
believe is that right oh that is right
oh how are bisexual musicians like the
iPad insert joke about orientation lock
[Music]
the boss oh this is it is this one this
is the end
[Music]
so cool I love it well that reminds me
of like the dead space ending or
something I don't know well alright then
well woah he's served his purpose I love
those rainbows right up until the end
let's get them
[Applause]
teamwork Bogg didn't even need to jump
in the water what was the point of that
okay yeah there we go got it that took a
while longer than it needs it to take
that right in your big bro sighs OH
oh it's time for a little investigation
let's see what's under this hot Oh Oh
tentacle beard huh pants oh you don't
have pants on those are just your hooves
well that's a little disturbing Oh
oh you did that pants tentacle penis
okay I just wanted to stop pelicans from
falling on you table F namaz la
ballerina
hey we're back to the beginning it's all
come full circle it's like the circle of
life kumbaya Lion King whatever oh man
that was nuts
that was awesome it was epic in every
way that was so cool
God knows awesome those so much more
involved in the first one that was
actually like legit in every way that
was amazing oh no - awesome the 3d can't
handle well his head exploded everyone's
dying it was so cool it was so cool you
don't need to thank me at all oh that
was it all those so cool I love that and
there's one more game in the series I
don't know if it's like super epic like
this or it's it even more or less
I don't know I'm gonna play it anyway so
let me know what you think of this game
in the comments below remember you can
play for yourself in the description
maybe there's some hidden achievements
that I didn't find in fact I'll look see
if there were yeah I didn't get
everything I missed something I don't
know what I did but there's a thumb Tom
I don't know but either way this stuff
that I didn't find so check it out for
yourself this game is amazing to the
developer this game awesome every part
of it amazed loved it loved it so why do
I thank you all so much for watching
check out the first part if you didn't
see it already in the comments or in the
description below or in the annotation
over there and thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
or in the next video
[Music]
[Music]